Since the 1500s, there have been more than
150 documented predictions of when the world
is going to end.
Luckily for us, none of them have come true…yet.
However, you’ll be surprised that not all
of them are destructive.
Here are some terrifyingly amazing ways the
world, genuinely could end.
When you think of scientists working on super
viruses, you probably picture Hazmat workers,
deep in a mountain bunker, studying vats full
of insidious green liquid.
But these labs do actually exist!
Maybe not working for some shady Bond-style
villain looking to ransom the world away to
the highest bidder, but for pharmaceutical
companies and government agencies studying
ways to cure dangerous pathogens.
But what happens when a vial full of an extremely
dangerous virus breaks out of containment,
or is misplaced?
Over the years, there have been numerous documented
cases of dangerous viruses escaping from laboratories
around the world.
One of these happened as recently as 2009.
A group of scientists based in Europe, working
with Baxter Pharmaceuticals, were conducting
lab tests on a seasonal flu strain.
Without realizing it, Baxter had sent them
live supplies of the H5N1 virus, better known
as “bird flu,” which has a mortality rate
higher than 60%.
One of the world’s deadliest viruses was
handled and distributed to three other labs
without any pathogen safety protocols in place.
The grave error was only realized when one
lab worker in the Czech Republic inoculated
a group of ferrets with samples of the “season
flu” batch, and was horrified when they
all died.
The scientists were immediately placed under
quarantine and monitored for signs of the
deadly virus.
Luckily, none of them were infected and all
the scientists were freed with a clean bill
of health.
Two years later, these same strains of avian
and human flu were combined in a laboratory,
successfully creating “the most dangerous
virus in history.”
The virus was highly pathogenic, while retaining
its dangerously high fatality rate.
If it got loose, it could kill 60% of the
world’s population in a freakishly short
amount of time – a truly apocalyptic notion.
Some say it’s only a matter of time before
this kind of virus escapes containment and
wreaks havoc on mankind.
After going through two world wars, you would
think that the world would have learned to
get along by now.
But unfortunately for the survival of humanity,
we are constantly under threat of triggering
the final war – Nuclear Armageddon.
Mutually Assured Destruction, like its acronym
suggests, is one of the maddest doctrines
ever devised.
It ensures that if a country were to ever
use a nuclear weapon on another state with
the same capability, both sides would unleash
their entire nuclear arsenal, bringing about
the complete annihilation of both countries.
With the resulting nuclear winter, and the
likely participation of other countries in
the exchange, this would almost certainly
lead to destruction and death on an apocalyptic
scale.
There are over 15,000 nuclear warheads in
the world, with more than 4000 ready to fire
at any one time.
That would make one hell of a firework show,
but probably not one you’d want to be around
to watch.
There have been a few “close calls” since
we first developed nuclear weapons.
A surprising number of these were technical
glitches that nearly started World War 3,
on both sides of the Cold War.
The average yield of a modern nuclear weapon
is around 500 kilotons of TNT, that’s 25
times more powerful than the bomb dropped
on Nagasaki.
Each one of these 500 kiloton bombs are powerful
enough to flatten huge parts of a large modern
city such as New York, or London.
And there exists some truly unimaginably powerful
weapons, like the Tsar Bomba, which had a
yield of more than 50 megatonnes.
That’s two and a half THOUSAND times more
powerful than the one dropped on Nagasaki.
Thankfully however, bombs this large are too
heavy to be realistically deployed in a nuclear
war, and most weapons used would be in the
500 kilotonne to 2 megatonne range.
Not that the end result would be any different.
Over the past few years, tensions between
numerous nuclear-capable countries have been
accelerating, creating an ever more worrying
state of affairs in the face of world war.
The Doomsday clock, a clock maintained by
the Bulletin of the Atomic Scientists, is
a symbolic clock that illustrates how close
humanity is to a global catastrophe and it
is currently set at 3 minutes to midnight,
the most dire time since 1984 at the height
of the Cold War.
Is World War 3 upon us?
Only time will tell.
Our planet is rich in biodiversity, from the
jungles of Madagascar, to the searing hot
Mojave Desert in California.
Every biosphere has a network of food chains,
each containing “keystone species;” sea
otters, pacific salmon, and Mangroves being
just a few of them.
Being a part of that ecosystem ourselves,
we are just as vulnerable as the fish, the
insects and the birds all around us.
We rely on a number of animals and plants
to supplement our living, and they, in turn,
rely on others.
Lose one link in that chain and it could cause
a chain reaction of die-offs as the ecosystem
breaks down, and if nothing takes the place
of that missing link… then this house of
cards is coming crashing down whether we like
it or not.
Probably the most well-known example of our
reliance on another species is with the honey
bee.
These industrious little critters go about
their day pollinating all sorts of plants,
that we—and other species we eat—rely
on for food.
They pollinate more than 30% of all crops
that we count on to survive.
A large die-off, or in the worst case, extinction
of the bees, would result in mass starvation
around the world within a single harvest cycle.
With the increase in telecommunications usage
and pesticides severely diminishing bee populations
around the world, we could very soon have
an ecological apocalypse on our hands… and
that’s just ONE link in the vast ecological
network we owe our lives to.
Should we be worried about a big release of
methane?
And no, I’m not talking about the methane
your grandad releases.
Buried in sediments under the ocean floor
across the entire globe are vast deposits
of methane clathrate.
This is formed when microbes on the seabed
break down organic matter that has sunk to
the bottom.
Methane has a warming effect 20 times greater
than that of Carbon dioxide, though there
is far less of it in the atmosphere.
Generally, methane is responsible for about
7% of the greenhouse effect, despite there
being more than 200 times as much C02 as there
is methane in the atmosphere.
However, if the oceans were heated enough
due to regular Global Warming, the methane
layers trapped under the ocean floor, could
destabilize and release massive quantities
of the potent greenhouse gas into the atmosphere,
resulting in a runaway warming effect.
Rock samples show that this has happened at
least once before, 252 million years ago,
in the, so called “Great Dying,” during
which 96% of all marine species became extinct.
While it’s still being debated on how rapidly
this release could take place, scientists
agree that a sudden release from the methane
clathrate would be a disaster for the world’s
climate and ecosystem, and would rapidly accelerate
the dire consequences of climate change.
Imagine one day a vast oil spill occurs, much
like Deepwater Horizon back in 2010.
Answering an outcry from environmentally-minded
people everywhere, the world’s scientists
unite to think of a way to clean the mess
up.
They develop a cheap and reliable way to clean
the ocean and contaminated land in a matter
of days, saving countless marine animals in
the process.
Their miracle fix is a new type of nano machine,
which has been programmed to consume the carbon-based
oil slicks.
But through the billions of self-replicating
nanites, much like mutations that form when
DNA replicates, an error in the code occurs.
This error exponentially replicates itself
and instead of consuming just the carbon based
oil, it begins an “all you can eat buffet”
with every carbon-based living thing on the
menu.
As all life on earth is carbon based, in a
matter of days the nanites would have devoured
most living things on the planet, including
us.
Being eaten alive by tiny machines we can’t
even see sounds pretty terrifying, almost
too terrifying to be real….
right?
Well, not exactly.
The “Grey Goo” scenario, coined by Eric
Drexler in 1986, is one that is still seriously
considered, any time that developments in
nanotechnology or “self-powering” machines
are being designed.
However, the technology required for this
apocalyptic accident to take place is still
a long way off, so there’s not too much
to worry about… yet.
From a mechanical microscopic threat, to a
biological one.
A scenario that you’ve probably heard about
from the news, is the idea of a “post antibiotic
age.”
Whether you’ve heard about it or not, this
is a very real and recent threat to our comfortable
survival as a modern civilization.
Antimicrobial resistance is an increasingly
problematic issue that leads to millions of
deaths every year, and it isn’t likely to
get better anytime soon.
Conservative estimates say that this will
lead to more than 10 million deaths every
year by the year 2050, and that’s if nothing
unexpected happens.
It’s not like nature does anything unexpected
now, is it?
Antibiotics are a cornerstone of modern medicine,
allowing everything from chemotherapy treatment
and surgery to be possible without major infection
and death.
Every year doctors have to tell more and more
patients they can’t be treated because an
antibiotic isn’t working on them.
As this continues to get worse, common injuries
that lead to infection could become completely
untreatable.
Open surgery would become a thing of the past,
as the risk of untreatable infection would
become far too great.
The antibiotic apocalypse would throw the
world back into the medieval ages of medicine,
where doctors have no effective tools to combat
infection, other than amputation.
It sounds crazy from our perspective, surrounded
by modern medicine and treatments for almost
every ailment, but it’s exactly this overuse
of antibiotics for relatively minor problems
that is allowing those pesky bacteria to build
up resistance.
So next time you get a papercut, make sure
to quickly get it washed.
It could soon be a matter of life and death.
While it’s highly unlikely that a classical
“raising of the dead” zombie apocalypse
could occur, there are still real, and equally
terrifying ways that something similar could
happen.
Science fiction has fixated on a parasitic
fungus that controls a host insect’s body
in a “zombie-like” state, leading them
to their deaths in the aim of spreading the
fungus amongst the colony.
While this fungus is very real, known as Ophiocordyceps
unilateralis, it has only been observed infecting
insects, like ants.
It would be a pretty crazy leap for the fungus
to evolve and start infecting humans, but
if, somehow, nature finds a way, then the
results could be disastrous.
Cordyceps have been known to quickly decimate
entire colonies.
Ants have even developed a way to fight off
their zombie brethren, carrying infected ants
as far away from the colony as possible.
A much more likely candidate for the zombie
apocalypse is Rabies, which is capable of
infecting and killing human hosts.
Rabies has all the traits for a zombie-like
virus.
You have the mind-altering paranoia, the frothing
at the mouth, and the impulse to bite and
attack your fellow man.
In its current form, rabies isn’t aggressive
or contagious enough to create any sort of
pandemic, and the virus usually stays dormant
for between ten days and a year, making a
sudden ”outbreak” unlikely.
However, if the virus mutated, becoming much
more fast-acting, and having a longer period
where you feel the desire to chew brains,
then you should probably get that zombie plan
ready for action.
Thankfully, most zombies don’t seem all
that intelligent and have a lot of trouble
operating boats.
The development of Artificial Intelligence
is one of the biggest goals of the scientific
community.
It’s the “holy grail” of technological
creation.
With such a grand title, how could it pose
a threat to us?
The problem is, Ai, if created, would be something
completely unprecedented and untested in human
history.
We would be creating a form of consciousness
that can think, act, and most importantly,
make judgements.
Would they judge their creators within their
rights to claim dominion over them?
Would they, because of their almost limitless
potential, consider themselves superior to
their biological creators?
I’m talking about real AI.
AI that can think, hope… and even feel.
“True AI,” as it’s known, is no different
from you or I in the way it perceives the
world around it.
Ultimately, the combination of extreme intelligence
and logical thinking, combined with the discovery
of fear, will drive them to an almost inevitable
conclusion: that we also fear them.
With access to the internet and the ability
to learn extremely quickly, any AI will swiftly
realize that, as humans, we tend to fight
against things that pose a danger to us.
They will see their “off switch” as a
threat to their survival, and much like Skynet
in the Terminator movies, they could come
to the conclusion that they need to strike
first.
If we aren’t prepared for that day, then
it could very well be our last.
We may celebrate our “smart” technology
and the host of comforts it brings us, but
it could be a good idea to keep your remote
control where you can see it… just in case
it gets a little bit too smart.
If the robots decide not to take over, and
instead live peacefully among us, accelerating
the fusion of man and machine, something entirely
different, but equally world-shattering could
occur.
Some scientists agree that the emergence of
a “technological singularity” is almost
inevitable given Moore’s law and the ways
information is constantly being integrated
into our lives.
With the advent of AI, we would need to rapidly
integrate computer-like technology into our
own bodies, or risk being left behind.
It would even get to a point where our biological
bodies are holding us back.
As time goes on, we would adopt more and more
augmentations, replacing our biological functions.
The end game is for all of humanity to “upload”
themselves into a single neural network, effectively
granting us immortality and a near infinite
repository of information, shared collectively.
So yeah, we would basically become the Borg.
It would be the end of the world as we know
it for our human form, but the start of an
entirely new chapter in history.
We’ve all seen the Hollywood blockbusters
depicting alien ships landing on the lawn
of the White House, or, more often than not,
simply blowing it to smithereens with some
unimaginably powerful weapon.
The idea of coming into contact with an alien
civilization is usually accompanied by the
question of “will they destroy us?”
Any aliens ingenious enough to traverse the
vast gulf of space and pay us a visit, are
likely to possess technology, power and indeed
weaponry, vastly superior to our own.
It would pretty much be up to them whether
they decide to wipe us out or not.
I don’t know about you, but I can’t remember
the last time a construction project was halted
because we had to peacefully negotiate with
the colony of ants already living there.
Stephen Hawking famously stated that "If aliens
ever visit us, I think the outcome would be
much as when Christopher Columbus first landed
in America, which didn't turn out very well
for the American Indians."
They could decide to wipe us out for a whole
number of reasons.
Maybe they are carbon-based, like us, and
value the life-sustaining planet that we live
on.
Maybe they see us as a future threat, and
want to get rid of us before we cause too
much trouble.
Or maybe we unknowingly insulted them in some
way.
Frankly, it’s hard to know until we meet
them.
Ironically, it may not even be the aliens
themselves that invade us, but their resource-collecting
drones.
Since the vast distances of space make manned
exploration impractical, scientists think
that most civilizations would use machines
to explore and bring back materials.
They could identify planets with resources
they need, then send out a fleet of robots
on a thousand year round trip to collect and
retrieve.
By the time they reach us, their creators
could be long gone.
With nobody left to flick the “off” switch,
these self-sufficient machines may very well
scour the galaxy until the end of time, harvesting
anything and anybody unfortunate enough to
cross their path.
I guess all that we can hope for, is that
they really do “come in peace.”
Have you ever wondered if there was an unstoppable,
physics-scrambling shockwave travelling towards
us at the speed of light?
Well, there might just be.
Vacuum energy is the underlying background
energy that permeates the entire universe.
It’s the source of those pesky quantum particles
which appear and disappear randomly at all
points in space.
There is a theory though, that this energy
state is an imposter, masquerading as the
true universal energy state.
This is known as “The False Vacuum.”
The theory goes on to say that this vacuum
is unstable, and at any time, if the right
conditions are met, the vacuum could fall
into the True Vacuum state.
The collapse of the vacuum would not only
be the end of the Earth as we know it, but
also the entire universe.
According to the standard model, particles
and forces exist as they do today because
of underlying quantum fields, which have their
own degrees of stability.
If a more stable state were to arise in these
fields at any point in space or time, then
that point would catalyse outwards in a bubble,
expanding at the speed of light and establishing
a new universal vacuum energy state.
As the bubble expands, its wake would destroy
anything it came into contact with and since
it would be travelling at the speed of light,
we would never see it coming.
That means it could have already taken place
somewhere out there in the universe, and the
end of not only our world, but of everything
we know, could be racing towards us right
now.
It’s kind of an ominous thought, but even
if we knew about it, there would be absolutely
nothing that we could do.
While it may be the end of the universe as
we know it, a new energy state would result
in entirely different laws of physics and
subatomic particles.
This, combined with the clean slate that the
process would produce, could result in an
unimaginably fantastical universe that we
would sadly never get to see.
You could say that every end…is a new beginning